[Music]
ethical self consciousness now learns
from its deed that developed nature of
what it actually did as much when it
abate divine law as when it followed
human law the law that is manifest to it
is linked in the essence with its
opposite the essence is the unity of
both that the deed has only carried out
one law in contrast to the other but the
two was being linked in the essence the
fulfillment of the water books the other
and the deed having made it so calls it
forth is a violated and now hostile
entity demanding revenge in the action
only one aspect of the resolve as such
as clearly manifest the resolve however
is in itself the negative aspect which
confronts the resolve with another with
something alien to the resolve which
knows what it does actuality therefore
holds concealed within it the other
aspect which is alien to this knowledge
and does not reveal the whole truth
about itself to consciousness the Sun
does not recognize his father and the
man who has wronged him and whom he
slaves nor his mother in the Queen whom
he makes his wife in this way a power
which shuns the light of day in snares
the ethical self-consciousness a power
which breaks forth only after the deed
is done and seizes the doer in the act
for the accomplished deed is the removal
of the antithesis between the knowing
self and the actuality confronting it
the doer cannot deny the crime or his
guilt the significance of the deed is
that what was unmoved has been set in
motion and that what was locked up and
mere possibility has been brought out
into the open hence to link together the
unconscious and the conscious non being
with being in this truth therefore the
deed is brought out into the light of
day as something in which the conscious
is bound up with the unconscious what is
one's own with what is alien to it as an
entity divided within itself whose other
aspects consciousness experiences and
also finds to be its own but as the
power it is violated and roused to
hostility
here in paragraph
469 where Hegel is continuing to work
out this dialectic between action and
doing and guilt and crime in terms of
these two laws and how they play
themselves out and how they express what
he's calling me any ethical substance
earlier on or now the ethical essence
Hegel is going to invoke something that
may be familiar to many of us and that
is the story of Oedipus this is best
known to us through Sophocles plays of
course there is a series a trilogy that
he has to do not only with Oedipus and
his mother and father but also with the
kids who result from it and Oedipus by
it by the first time there's been this
you know tragic and his mother has
killed herself he's killed his father
worse than that he is married his mother
reigned as king for a long time sought
for the killer of his father without
realizing that he was the very man all
that you know happens in the first part
but then there's there's a continuance
and the Antigone which is played as
that's playing an extremely central role
here in in Hegel's thought is part of
that sequence here in this particular
paragraph we are looking primarily at
the example of Oedipus and we'll see how
he fits in there so you want to stay
tuned to that one thing I do want to get
out of the way immediately however is
don't import floyd-- Oedipus complex or
whatever you happen to think about it or
have heard about it into reading this
section Hegel of course antedates Freud
by almost a century not not quite but
you know certainly more than half of a
century and he is doing something quite
different with Oedipus and and if this
is children then is Freud in his talk
about the complex Freud is primarily
focused on design
and family dynamics in terms of that
Hagel is focused on something else
action and knowledge and guilt
so Hagel says ethical self-consciousness
learns from it deed to develop nature of
what it actually did there's a little
bit of a convoluted translation here it
actually begins in the German by talking
about the handle the the action what
we're translating here is what it
actually did right and what we see here
is there's a doing which then is is
consolidated we might say in something
identifiable as an action or we might
take important if we like as well some
something definite right so ethical
self-consciousness learns from its deed
the developed nature of what it actually
did it's finding out more in what it
actually did that it was experiencing in
it deed originally and Hegel goes on and
tells us as much when it obeyed divine
laws when it followed human law so we
could pick either side but in either
case what is happening is this this same
dynamic and it's possible for you know
the person who's following the divine
law to engage in action that is then
going to violate the human law it is
quite likely that the person is
following the human law is also going to
violate the divine law in some way at
least at this point in the conflict
between the ethical powers right so he
goes on and he says the law that is
manifest to it is linked in the essence
with its opposite the law that the
self-consciousness is is grasping as
ethical self-consciousness is linked to
the other law it's inescapable
although ethical self consciousness can
be blinded by its its allegiance to one
of these laws and its
in fact deep loyalty that in expressing
the laws it doesn't escape the other law
by doing so so he says the essence of
the unity of both of these laws but the
deed has only carried out one law in
contrast to the other so we have a sort
of splitting taking place here Hegel has
already discussed this in previous
paragraphs as this you know enactment of
the the one side against an alien
reality of the other side and now that
alien reality is going to exert its own
agency its own force
so Hegel tells us the two laws being
linked in the essence the fulfilment of
the one evokes the other and the deed
having made it so calls it forth
now as violent as having been broken and
this is where guilt and crime are going
to emerge now notice how Hegel talks
about it here though the guilt and crime
exist on the side of the
self-consciousness the law itself is
going to express itself or be evoked or
arise as a hostile entity an enemy in
fact demanding revenge aha his
retribution would be another way of
saying it so in the action he says only
one aspect of the resolve the ench loose
the decision the contain you know
containing itself within itself you
might say is clearly manifest but the
resolve he says is in itself the
negative aspect which confronts the
resolve with another so what does that
mean that means that this very action of
resolve this is almost high daguerreian
and what Hegel is saying here right the
very
sort of containing within itself carried
out by the acting person this
consolidation and condensation leads to
the other law because again we have the
same logic of the self same repelling
itself from itself or casting itself out
and what does it cast itself out to the
other law it finds that there is more to
the story than it originally construed
itself as doing how does it find this it
finds it not by like sitting and
speculating and saying oh I wonder how
this is going to turn out I really want
to have a full adequate picture of
things speculatively
so I need to work this out for myself
no it will be through a drama in which
other people are going to arrive on the
scene and eventually one confronts one's
own guilt so he says as a beautiful way
of expressing it here actuality
therefore holds concealed within it the
other aspect which is alien to this
knowledge and does not reveal the whole
truth about itself to consciousness the
example here is again of Oedipus the son
does not recognize his father and the
man who has wronged him and whom he
slays nor the mother in the Queen whom
he makes his wife now what does Haga lot
about here why is this example
particularly apt so it might be helpful
to understand a little bit more of the
particulars of the story of Odysseus and
that is Oedipus I'm sorry although it is
yes for me very interesting here as well
so Oedipus is born to a king and a queen
and
there's a prophecy that he's going to
kill his father and marry his mother and
so being you know decent parents I won't
say good parents but decent parents they
they say well we've got to do away with
this kid and now notice it's not just
about a family and family norms not
being violated or incest taboos or
something like that this is a king and a
queen they cannot have sort of debacle
happening to their their country and so
he sent you know he's supposed to be
actually exposed and killed but he winds
up being fostered in Corinth by the king
and queen there and eventually he finds
out about the the prophecy himself and
says oh I am NOT going to stick around
and do that sort of thing to mom and dad
I better get the hell out of town what
ends up happening well he goes back to
themes where he's originally from and he
meet the man along the way and this man
has a chariot and tells him to get the
hell out of the way and he says I'm not
getting out of the way you get out of
the way and he killed them and then he
goes on and he gets to town and when he
gets to town you know not long after
that they find out somebody killed the
king and Oedipus says look a pair of
terrible you know but I'm a pretty tough
guy I'll make sure there's law and order
here I'll marry that Queen that you've
got there she's very pretty by the way
you know and he does and they have all
sorts of children together and the whole
time you know he's looking for an answer
to this question who killed the king who
killed my predecessor now what had
happened here as Hegel tells us the son
had not recognized the father in the man
that he was opposed to almost the
opposite of the Freud reference isn't it
he doesn't recognize his father in the
person who he winds up in a rivalry he
and ends up you know killing according
to the human law the divine law would
tell them no no you cannot do something
like that to your father you have to
obey your father or something along
those lines the human law says look this
guy got in your way and threatened you
you get to kill them but then it also
tells that at this you should punish the
person who killed the ruler before you
the ruler do your job and make sure that
that happens likewise with the mother he
doesn't know that the the person that he
is marrying the queen is indeed his
mother the one who he makes his wife so
we have a double not knowing in in this
case so what does Hegel tell us about
this in this way a power which shuns
this is the light of day in snares the
ethical self-consciousness that's a
really interesting way to talk about it
the power would shun the light of day
and snares the ethical
self-consciousness a power which breaks
forth only after the deed is done and
seizes the doer in the act
you know Oedipus did not proceed again
it was why we want to put Freud away
Oedipus did not say I really want to
kill my dad and marry my mom that's
that's what I'm all about
no he wants to do the opposite of that
and the very fact of that being
mentioned is what provokes him to take
the course of action that he does which
ends up killing his mom killing his dad
and marrying his mom so there's
something going on here that isn't just
in self-consciousness or if it is it's
something very subterranean something
almost cathodic and it only comes out to
say got you out after the deed has been
done it's the sort of thing where you
actually feel it rather unfair but you
don't even get to really say that it's
unfair because everybody by that time is
pointing the finger at you including
yourself and saying guilt crime
look at what you've done so Hegel goes
on he tells us the doer cannot deny the
crime or is guilt once it's come out now
everything makes sense but in making
sense it's terrible you know very often
talk it is a bit of a digression as if
learning the truth will set you free
it really depends on what that truth is
doesn't it this is there are some truths
where perhaps innocent and not innocent
ignorant is not exactly bliss but it's
certainly not being tormented by what it
is that you have done and the
consequences of your action so maybe
sometimes you don't actually want to
know but in this case the person can't
avoid that so he says this is this
beautiful thing right after that the
accomplished deed is the removal of the
antithesis between the knowing self and
the actualities confronting it now the
term there that Hegel is using for
removal this is actually Alf Haven in
this case oklahoman right
describing the opposition or the
antithesis that has has now been
sublated has been has been removed has
been incorporated you might say and he
tells us that here we go the antithesis
between the knowing self and the
actualities confronting it is is gone
the doer cannot deny the crime or his
guilt why not
because now he knows it to be the case
and remember this is an ethical doer to
begin with this is an ethical
self-consciousness this is not just you
know some person wandering around trying
to do something fun or interesting or
having adventures this is somebody who
is actually trying to do what is right
trying to find the truth
of who they are and what indeed human
beings are and what they find out is
they have done something perhaps
irrevocable perhaps terrible
perhaps totally unprecedented he goes on
and he says the significance of the deed
is that what was unmoved has been set in
motion set in motion by who by one's
choice by one's action by one's starting
the whole process in motion in this case
again
Oedipus he tells everybody go out and
find out who indeed killed my
predecessor not realizing his
predecessor as his father and the fact
that he himself is the man who did it so
he says what was locked up in mere
possibility has been brought out into
the open hence to link together now
notice what Hegel saying here to link
together the unconscious and the
conscious non being with being that is
part of what action does is links
non-being with being there's a
metaphysical aspect to action so in the
truth
therefore the deed is brought out into
the light of day as something in which
the conscious is bound up with the
unconscious in which what is one's own
with what is alien to it as an entity
divided within itself whose other aspect
consciousness experiences and also finds
to be its own but as the power it is
violated and roused to hostility so what
is he saying there again discussion of
the conscious and unconscious probably
wants to make you think here of Freud
and of invoking him but I think despite
the fact that we're talking about
Oedipus in this very passage that may
not be that helpful how can we make
sense of this in terms of the conscious
and the unconscious just on its own face
here in Hegel without assuming some
thing like a unconscious or subconscious
to a person and without assuming
something perhaps like a collective
unconscious well we could just take the
words as what they mean there is a
structure out there here we start to
move more towards somebody who is in
fact an Orthodox Freudian in certain
respects but also extremely innovative
in others and that would be Chaka Khan
the unconscious is not necessarily my
unconscious or the unconscious of you
know humanity writ large
instead it's something that is
structured with a coherent but not
understood system and if you think about
the family relations in the Oedipus
story there is something like that it's
not just family relations it's family
relations intersecting with political
relations intersecting with narrative
and nobody really puts together all the
pieces except for of course in Sophocles
version the poor blind guy who sees the
horrible thing that has not only is
about to take place but has taken place
the fact that Oedipus has already by
that time killed his father married his
mother not only married his mother but
produce progeny with his his mother this
guilt this crime that's taking place is
bringing together the conscious and the
unconscious of Hegel is saying again
non-being with being so he says the deed
has brought out into the light of day as
something in which the conscious is
bound up with the unconscious what is
one's own with what is alien to it
Oedipus did not say as I point it out
yeah that's exactly what I want to do
what would he tried to do again
following the ethical following what he
actually took to be right and what what
right in some respects turns out to also
be tragically wrong and he finds himself
unable to extricate himself from the
situation of guilt crime and shame worse
to go on further not only has he screwed
up his own life and those of his parents
he's also implicated his children within
this entire structure and that is going
to turn out to be a fate that they
cannot escape this is going a little bit
beyond what Hegel is talking about here
in this passage but I think it is worth
dwelling on a bit the narratives in
which these sorts of things play out you
know doing in accordance with one law
violating another law in the process
both of these actually being norms that
express the ethical and which which do
exist in some way in self consciousness
the one known the other one unknown the
one conscious the other one unconscious
all of this plays itself out not only
within the scope of the single person's
existence but within generations and
that is part of what the law of the
family or the divine law is able to
emphasize for us it also plays itself
out within the larger society or culture
or use Hegel's term that he likes to use
so much the nation there are
generational guilts that are carry and
sometimes acquiring knowledge about that
is actually going to intensify the
problem and make it more acute we're
placed in the interesting sort of
quandary is it better just not to know
and to conceal things well if you do
that here's where actually there is
something similar to Freud going on here
Freud talked about the return
of the repressed when you attempt to
repress to you know the dragon push
below something sooner or later it's
going to come out it may not just be
things like desires that were not
particularly happy that we have it could
also be a deadly history in which
people's rights were violated and people
had to you know change their whole way
of thinking in order to be able to feel
okay with these people's rights or
whatever we want to call it having been
transgressed this is part of you know
what's what's going on and the guilt and
crime may be something that we inherit
and take on even though we did not
ourselves originally create those
through our action through our doing so
he says that we wind up here with an
entity divided within itself whose other
aspect consciousness experiences and
finds it to be its own but as the power
it is violated and roused to hostility
when we violate the one law in the favor
of the other law sooner or later that
other that first law is going to come
looking for us and it's going to exact
it's as Hegel called it here revenge
it's raka it's retribution upon us it is
after all the law so all of that is
something we want to keep in mind as
we're now moving into the next paragraph
where we're going to see even more
discussion of the Oedipus cycle but now
framed in terms of children